so we have two different logarithmic
expressions here one in yellow and one
in this pinkish color and what i want
you to do like always pause the video
and see if you can rewrite each of these
logarithmic expressions in a simpler way
and i'll give you a hint in case you
haven't started yet the hint is is that
if you think about how you might be able
to change the base of the logarithmic or
the logarithms or the logarithmic
expressions you might be able to
simplify this a good bit and i'll give
you even a further hint
when i'm talking about change of base
i'm saying that if i have the log
base and i'll color code it log base a
of b
log base a
of b
this is going to be equal to
log of b
log of b
over
log of a
over
log of a
now you might be saying wait wait we
wrote a logarithm here but you didn't
write what the base is well this is
going to be true regardless of which
base you choose as long as you pick the
same base this could be this could be
base 9
base 9 in either case now typically
people choose base 10
so 10 is the most typical one to use and
that's because most people's calculators
or there might be logarithmic tables 4
base 10. so here you're saying the the
exponent that i have to raise a to to
get to b
is equal to the exponent i have to raise
10 2 to get to b divided by the exponent
i have to raise 10 to to get to a
this is a really really useful thing to
know if you are dealing with logarithms
and we prove it in in another video but
now let's see if we can apply it
so going back to this yellow expression
this once again is the same thing as 1
divided by
this right over here so let me write it
that way actually this is 1
divided by
log
base b
of 4.
well let's use what we just said over
here to rewrite it so this is going to
be equal to
this is going to be equal to 1
divided by
instead of writing it log base b of 4 we
could write it as
log
of 4
and if i just if i don't write the base
there we can assume that it is base 10
log of 4
over
log of b
now if i divide by
some from fraction or some rational
expression that's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal so this is
going to be equal to 1 times the
reciprocal of this
log
of b
over
log
of 4 which of course is just going to be
log of b
over log of 4. i just multiplied it by
1.
and so we can go in the other direction
now using this little tool we
established at the beginning of the
video this is the same thing as
log base 4
of b
log base 4
of b
so we have we have a pretty neat result
that actually came out here we didn't
prove it for any values although we have
a pretty general b here
if i take
the if i take the
reciprocal
of
a logarithmic expression i essentially
have swapped the bases this is log base
b
what exponent have to raise b 2 to get
to 4
and then here i have what exponent do i
have to raise 4 to to get to b
now it might seem a little bit magical
until you actually put some some
tangible numbers here then it starts to
make sense especially relative to
fractional exponents for example we know
that 4 to the third power is equal to
64. so if i had log
base 4 of 64
that's going to be equal to 3
and if i were to say log
base 64
of 4 well now i'm going to have to raise
that to the 1 3 power so notice they are
the reciprocal of each other so actually
not so magical after all but it's nice
to see how everything fits together
now let's try to now let's try to tackle
this one over here so i have log base c
of 16 times log
base 2
of c
all right
so this one once again it might be nice
to rewrite these each of these as as a
rational expression dealing with log
base 10. so this first one
this first one i could write this as
log
base 10 of 16
remember if i don't write the base you
can assume it's 10
over
log
over
log base 10 of c
and we're going to be multiplying this
by
now this is going to be we could write
this as
log base 10 of c
log base 10 of c
over
over
log base 10 of 2
log
base 10 of 2. once again i could have
these little tens here if it makes you
comfortable
i could do something like that but i
don't have to and now this is
interesting because if i'm multiplying
by log of c and dividing by log of c
both of them base 10
well those are going to cancel out and
i'm going to be left with
log base 16
sorry log base 10
of 16
over
over log base 10
of 2.
and we know how to go the other
direction here this is going to be
is going to be the logarithm
log
base 2 of 16
log
base 2
of
16 and we're not done yet because all
this is is what power do i need to raise
2 to to get to 16 i'll have to raise 2
to the i have to raise 2 to the 4th
power
the blue color
to raise 2 to the 4th power to get to
16. so that's this is kind of a cool
thing because in the beginning i started
with this variable c it looks like we're
going to deal with a pretty abstract
thing but you can actually evaluate this
this kind of crazy looking expression
right over here evaluates to the number
four in fact if i had to run some type
of a mat scavenger hunt or something
this could be a pretty good clue for
evaluating two four you know walk this
many steps in the forward or something
it would be pretty cool